I think I only brought about five
essentials this made me realize that
maybe I'm quite the minimalist how can
you have ten things that's like a full
bag of stuff
hello GQ I'm Matty from the 1975 and
these are my essential items
I'm always traveling so I'm always on
planes I'm always led to be fair if I
had like too much stuff with me it would
make my life a nightmare if I was too
reliant on things
there's some things I always need to
have with me as well but I didn't in
there are very responsible things to
advertise on here so I just kept it's
like domestic thing quality not quantity
sunglasses is a Wayfarers I'm feeling
quite classic at the moment got quite a
lot of sunglasses a lot of my life is
performing right I get really paranoid
about like rock star cliches so I've got
loads of sunglasses but I very seldom
wear them because like I don't want to
be like that guy even though I do look
better with sunglasses we can all agree
I do look better
yeah I'm not specific really I like
cheap stuff a lot of time Santa Monica
Pier like $5 rubbish glasses
a little Minority Report headphones I
wanted to not like them right because
everyone looks a bit like looks kind of
funny I was like why don't we need a
wire like why why get rid of the wire I
get it now
I don't come out I'm very fortunate to
have a life where if I am walking
through that central London most days
like at least someone will come over and
be like say something to me say hello
and it stops that's good because I'm
constantly what yeah sorry yeah winner
for me these ones I've really embraced
the iPhone have some really weird Taco
Bell cover and the hive is real
Taco Bell it's because we got sent loads
of like merchandise versions of phone
case like a 1975 one I just took all the
basic ones my notes like I'd soon I have
somebody read every text message I've
ever sent to anybody than like read my
notes yeah I mean there's some really
personal [ __ ] in these things we've even
used the iPhone till I can like record
on this last record mean George what a
really boxy kind of snare drum before
since era is scary so a lot of the mids
of the snare had done on an iPhone the
quality of microphone in these things is
amazing there's this whole vision of the
future that everything was gonna be tiny
right and now we're getting bigger you
can do really amazing inventive things
with them and I like him I remember in
my other notebook he stabbed with me I
was like a reward at the front it says
cool I put five grand this is in 2014
because I didn't even have 5 grams it's
my name at that time why would you need
a notebook if you've got a phone right
if you do the same thing it's a kind of
fair point really it's not that there's
any kind of like romance to having a
notebook but I really like typewriters
as well I don't have one with me because
that is really impractical and the thing
is with typewriters and writing on with
pen to paper there's a kind of an
element of like commitment
that goes with the ceremony of it
therefore it requires you to concentrate
a bit better so I think is important to
have a book it says mainly like stories
that I write about dreams of being in
love with other pop stars 500 in that
one my laptop thing is probably even
more essential to me than like a guitar
any kind of write into a computer
nowadays we'd be more lost without a
laptop every word kind of actual
physical instruments what do I use a lot
of it's just all very very basic musics
that it's logic and notes are the two
things are open so there you go it's my
bag this is the bag this the bag that
goes everywhere with me this is the bag
that stopped me from losing things
because people can just like tie around
my neck and send me away disposable
camera passport my wallet this is my
getaway quickly bag I think oh that's
kind of chic that makes me look like
kind of a modern man some kind of
aftershave thing I don't know something
French
Mason Louie Marie smell it it's a bit
like labo but you don't smell like every
other person it's our house which is
always a good way know that go to our
house but it's like that kind of smell
it just smells like so house Santa
wherever they call it I think it's like
a cheap one of those it doesn't smell
like really strong as well I hate it
like where people it's just ho no one
asked for that like coming up here that
all that smell my house keys
and I go dude on it I went to a wedding
not gonna go and had these on the table
love that great idea goodbye I'm
thinking that I want to eyes shitload of
these and then give them to the front
row of a show so everyone kind of gets
one and then they can either take it
with them at the end I'm gonna get it
developed or like get someone with a bin
in to what bus and they put it in there
and then we get it developed you know
I'll just do it we just have them it
would be a nice thing to have right I'm
gonna have anything interesting in the
wallet my driver knows this most
organized I've ever been anything I've
ever had my driving license ID my
passport on me at the same time and my
house keys a my my thing I have ten
essentials now that's me in a nutshell